as reality shows go american pickers is
a pretty laid-back one the concept of
two guys driving around america to
discover hidden treasures from people's
attics barns and garages has proved so
popular with the viewers that the show
has almost two dozen seasons under its
belt and the good-natured haggling
element adds just enough fun tension to
the road trip vibe of the series well
i'll tell you one thing he's got a nose
for good crap 50 bucks absolutely all
right i mean that guy's like a
bloodhound he just went right to it
unfortunately the show's chill facade
eventually fell apart revealing a nasty
rift between its main duo since it first
came to light much has been said about
the feud between american pickers hosts
mike wolfe and frank fritz in short
after fritz suddenly stopped appearing
on american pickers the two reality tv
stars shared a series of public
statements about one another revealing
what appears to have been a considerable
tension underscoring their former
working relationship as a result fritz's
absence from the show continues and will
by all accounts remain permanent that
said during the 20 full seasons and
handful of season 21 episodes for its
co-hosted american pickers he left an
indelible mark on the series for example
fritz at one point claimed that each of
the scenes in which he and wolf meet
with prospective antique sellers are
unscripted can we take big blue out of
the cabinet nobody touches big glue
oh
all right he then cited the value of
filming genuine human moments as one of
his favorite aspects of the job which
shows a genuine warmth that no doubt
contributed to his appeal as a tv host
on one particular occasion however an
attempt at a comedic bit framed fritz as
unnecessarily petty out of the many many
scenes of the show this may very well
have been the single frank fritz moment
from american pickers that went too far
season 13 episode 14 of american pickers
includes a scene in which frank fritz
drives a van while mike wolf speaks to
an unseen third party on his cell phone
in its passenger seat although wolff is
negotiating a transaction fritz argues
that his business dealings are taking
too long and are an unwelcome staple of
virtually all of their numerous road
trips that's 31. 31 minutes about the
same motorcycle the last time i drove
the van in silence was when
oh that's right never some on-screen
math then accompanies fritz calculating
just how much time he's typically
subjected to sitting silently through
wolf's phone conversations given the
nature of most reality tv shows this is
fairly likely a scripted comedy bit
nevertheless the scene characterizes
fritz as a bitter and discourteous
partner who takes issue with the fact
that his co-host chooses to use his down
time to conduct business in light of the
fact that fritz and wolfe are no longer
on speaking terms this scene is all the
more egregious it's now irrevocably
colored by what seems to have been a
very real friendship ruining tension
full days and full nights of my life are
spent listening to mike wolf talk on the
phone
when two people spend a bunch of time
together it's not unheard of for one to
slowly build up a dislike toward what
they see as the others disagreeable
habits since parting ways with the show
fritz hasn't hesitated to throw a few
verbal daggers in wolf's direction as
evidenced by a july 2021 interview with
the sun where he said i haven't talked
to mike in two years he knew my back was
messed up but he didn't call me up and
ask how i was doing that's just how it
is he also insinuated that the two men
aren't exactly on great terms and that
he feels wolf may have wanted his exit
so he could make his brother robbie wolf
a full co-host of the show while fritz
didn't outright insult wolfe too harshly
he made clear that he thinks his former
co-host has turned against him fritz
also revealed that he feels that the
fans like him more even though wolfe is
the clear focal point of the show yep
that's a biggie no heart and soul
rewatch the cell phone scene with
knowledge of such comments and you might
find yourself wondering just how far
gone the two men's friendship was at
that point i mean
what a conversation piece
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite reality shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]